all right when you watch this kid play
you know that baseball's in good hands
for quite some time to come folks in
Houston certainly know about that no
about that and the all-star third
baseman of the Houston Astros right here
in the Los Angeles studios of the Rich
Eisen show good to see you Alex pretty
to see you you bet
let's just talk a little bit about what
we talked about all fair what are you
doing in Los Angeles just hanging out
yes working out kind of trying to get
into the content game a little bit try
to mark it mark it a little bit better I
mean I think I think the NFL and NBA do
a great job of marketing and I think
their players have a lot to do with that
and I think our players need to get out
and start showing their personalities
and start showing who they are and I
think I think that's a big thing that we
need to work on this offseason Monday
myself and a few other guys that are
playing in the big leagues former big
leaguers or I'll be working out on the
beach kind of talking shop kind of
coming up with ideas to market ourselves
better drop some names are you gonna be
with Clorox don't don't worry I just
understand this you are talking to a
first-rate name dropper so however you
draw paint right hey Robby is that a
good day that's a young Blake's no okay
here Cole correct Carlos Correia look at
that we're gonna sit down talk shop and
hopefully figure out some good ideas
going forward to how to market ourselves
better well I'll tell you on the air
what I told you off the air just to
bring it to everyone here is not enough
baseball players call into shows like
this one
not enough ballplayers take the time on
some 10 game road trip to just carve out
15 minutes of the day to chop it up I
mean we have NFL players on here all the
time
NBA players would call in every now and
then but baseball players just aren't I
don't know if they're it's because they
they don't feel the need or they think
it's not necessary well I think then I
think the new the new
the New Age the new generation of
players is willing to do that and I
think we need to get out like you said
and get out and get on shows like this
get out in the community get on TV shows
get on do cameos and movies stuff like
that and I think if we really want to
market ourselves like the NBA and the
NFL market their players then we need to
be open to doing that and and taking the
time out of our day to do it well I mean
you've got your own YouTube channel now
currently twenty seven thousand
subscribers and you spent the because
you're an LSU guy you spent the LSU
Texas A&M game watching on your
Instagram live feed is that what you
were doing I was calling on some fans
some LSU fans trying to talk to them and
just what give them like a watch the
game with me experience so it's pretty
cool I know I that would be dangerous
it's like if I would never have
Instagram live fed me watching the
Michigan Ohio State game in a million or
I turn it off when we lost because I
there's some stuff I can say on
Instagram why when coach OH got that
premature Gatorade bath to man oh man I
knew I was I knew that was bad I know I
just had that little feeling you had
that little feeling it wasn't gonna go
well especially when we saw some of the
players cramping up later on they like
can we get some extra Gatorade they ran
out I guess or just like I thought they
were gonna like wring his shirt out of
the extra Gatorade just to get some
amounts of can you imagine how that
feels playing seven over times that's
weird if I couldn't have imagined that I
must have been dead I am NOT a fan of
the college overtime I'm just not a fan
of it because it takes special teams out
of play you know I mean it would and
that's why I'm glad baseball hasn't done
in major leagues yet what I've heard
they've been doing ugh I hope not which
is let's put somebody on second base to
start extra innings I hope not I like
how baseball is traditionally played I
think that'd be ridiculous if we put
somebody at second base well that's the
way that's that that's what I'm hearing
it's been it's being done on certain
minor league affiliates you would not be
up for that
Oh No okay what about would you be up
for reconfiguring the lineup in the
ninth inning no matter who
matter what that you've hit me eight
you're down and you're up in the ninth
now selfishly yes because I'd want to
hit again in the night no I like kind of
I'm a baseball purist I kind of like
hell I don't even I don't even really
like replay that might because I was one
for ten on replays this year myself what
do you mean you were one for ten on
replay haha if I was involved in a
replay this year and we challenged it we
did not win didn't matter what it was
would you it's not it's the Bellas curse
this year in replays it's not it's not
AJ Hinch it's you know no big made the
Gert they made the right call to replay
it it was just I think I was cursed or
something somebody in New York you don't
like replay I mean replayed I think yeah
I'm a replay guy in the NFL base yeah I
mean in baseball I'd you know I think
it's necessary for certain place you
know took away a few hits from me you
know I'm sure doesn't take away too many
hits for you is the shift right cuz it
does to me it does even for right-handed
hitters yeah they they move the second
baseman for me now right behind second
base up the middle
so you hit it right up the middle and I
go that's it that's a base hit so you
don't change your approach based on the
on the shift at all or no you do you do
I'd I try and hit everything in the air
to left field and on the line to right
field but right when you miss and you're
trying to do that it's you're hitting it
right into the shift is that right your
your manager loves the shift man loves
it he's just more than anybody so do you
just like roll your eyes cuz you're all
over the place or what like how many
times are you on the right field right
side a second base Alex um well I my
when I play shortstop I'm over there
most of the time when lefties are
hitting but since since I played short
growing up and through college and
everything right I actually feel
comfortable in the shift because they
just slide me from third right back to
shortstop when I left he said mm-hm and
I feel like I got to play both short and
third ok so you get your cardio in that
way pretty much oh yeah and he had me
the first game of the season Joey Gallo
comes up he had me run out to left field
and do a four-man outfield for Joey run
back in so the cardio is definitely good
what was the last time you played how
few oof
Detroit my rookie year in 2016 and
that's the last time I played outfield
for a good reason
what happened over through the cutoff
man and
winning run came into score so you said
hey kid you're gonna stick the third
Alex Bregman here on the Rich Eisen show
yeah I asked your manager if because we
had Scott Boras the the agent on the
show the other day and he says that that
shift is biased against left-handed
hitters because yeah because you can put
four guys on the right side of second
base for lefty but you can't do that for
righty because somebody's got to play
first base
exactly so I asked your manager I asked
Dave Roberts of the Dodgers and then
your manager of the Red Sox or Cora my
guy how was your guy here's our bench
coastal realty yeah that's right
so um none of them would entertain the
idea of having an anti shift rule put in
where it's got to be at least two guys
on either side of second and at least
one foot on the infield
of everybody you don't agree with that I
don't like it no why I think that I like
this shift won us a World Series so I'm
biased in that yeah so it's all about
you Alex
no here you are coming on soon you're
gonna try and sell yourself and sell the
game you're you you have a great sense
of everything and but it's about you
okay all right so all right let's help
you out here you said that you wouldn't
mind being a cameo of some sort right
the television a movie what what what
would you if you could wave a wand what
show would you want to be in I'm not
sure I'd want to do like I'd want to do
some sort of movie like what but give me
give me sort of like sports comedy movie
sports comedy like fun okay sports
comedy movie the Knicks something to do
with the next major league major league
like major league three or four playing
yourself or playing so I'll be fine okay
hey there's Alex Bregman that cuz you
know Bad News Bears breaking training
did involve the Houston Astros back in
the day damn I totally oh my god I
forgot I'm talking to somebody who's but
you're how old are you 24 oh my gosh you
don't even know what I'm talking about
right
[Music]
someone else with movie loopholes hold
on a second
Alex before you were born way before you
were born the bad news bears you've
heard about that right of course
okay they did a sequel called the bad
news bears breaking training where the
Bad News Bears played in the Houston
Astrodome oh wow and the game was called
because the Houston Astros were playing
a game and the entire Houston Astros
team did a cameo in the movie in the
movie yes and they all chanted to let
them play let them play and they I can't
believe I'm explaining this down 1977 oh
my god okay old man yes they did so
you'd want to do something like that
with you and the whole Houston Astros
team right sure for sure I think we'd
have a blast with it let's get let's get
it all working once again yeah what else
booze bears what sports movie franchise
needs like a reboot well I mean I think
there is most of another major league
movie actually coming you know they're
doing Space Jam so alright we could get
something like that is there any
particular actress that you would like
to work a scene with Alex Bregman can we
help you in this regard I'm not sure yet
a lot of them Alex Alex you the Gretzky
phrase that they used to say that you
you misunderstood the shots you don't
take
you missed a hundred percent of the
shots you don't take we'll go off Olivia
culpo yeah that is miss universe
I believe Tim Tebow is no longer with
her granny Amendola
Danny Amendola yeah they've been on
again off again let's let's uh do we
Mike do you have that number on speed
dial do you have Olivia okay so Bad News
Bears six with the Houston Astros and
Olivia culpa and let's let's go pitch it
let's get a wrong involved he's got the
money he can produce it
a Rajan okay now you were number two why
well I wore number two because I love
Derek Jeter growing up captain my mom's
favorite player we always watch my mom
loved the Yankees growing up so I always
rooted for the Red Sox why Alex Bregman
knew I liked you because we always we
always rooted against who my mom was
rooting for my dad my little brother my
sister we all rooting for the Red Sox
because she would rub it in our face 26
championships the whole deal so we'd
always root for the Red Sox but I always
had it I always always admired Jeter as
a baseball player so you personally
wrecked Derek Jeter day huh from the
plate right how many home runs did you
hit that night when they retired Derek
Jeter's number one Grand Slam it was my
first it was my first uh Grand Slam in
the first inning correct yep just to end
the entire night on the spot it was like
ain't nothing after that but then what
else did you that was not your only hit
that night right no no a few a few more
so we're watching it right now on Derek
Jeter night on Sunday Night Baseball so
your mom you broke her heart that night
too
yeah she was kind of sad she showed up
she said she showed up for Mother's Day
but I really know she showed up I
guarantee you she probably wanted the
Yankees to win that night did you meet
Jeter that night I did Carlos Beltran
one of my oh sure
one of our teammates was really close
with Derek's got a shake his hands say
hello to him but I met Derek for the
first time at LSU Alabama football game
he came to tailgate with CC Sabathia and
when I was when I was a freshman in
college and a really nice guy okay
have you seen him since wrecking his
night I haven't seen him I haven't sees
avoiding you I think
okay so then when you eliminated the
Yankees from the playoffs
you broke your mother's heart there too
Alex right think she was okay with it
because it was the postseason then she
was rude she was ruined for me in the
postseason
so okay but now we understand yeah okay
where it was all working exact for you
in that postseason all right and so what
what did that World Series mean for you
I mean how
did you soak all that in yes I mean the
dream come true you dream about that
growing up as a kid to win a World
Series you you watch it every year you
you put yourself in those in those
moments whether you're in the cul-de-sac
with your dad at five years old you're
like all right bottom of the ninth World
Series let's do it if we get a hit here
we win and just to be able to see the
smiles on all those guys faces after we
going through the whole grind from
Spring Training all the way through the
end of the year just so special and you
you got to cherish it because you don't
know if you'll ever be able to do it
again I I was fortunate enough to win in
my first year first full season Carlos
Beltran played 20 years in right and he
won his this last year so you cherish it
and then it just motivates you more to
work every day to towards winning
another one yeah and then this year was
just did you just feel more confident
see the ball better I mean what was it
this year for you I think yeah I think
just getting accustomed uh how how the
big leagues works kinda the it's it's a
huge jump from the minor league so it's
just this stuff is unbelievable the the
command of all of all the pitches the
the game planning about they know they
know exactly where your holes are where
they where they can get you out it's a
constant cat-and-mouse game of making
adjustments so this year made a few few
better adjustments than the year before
well it's been a great run in the city
Houston obviously with what's going on
with your team hardened in the rocket
set an amazing year last year JJ Watt
and the Texans they're now eight and
three so you're rooting for the Texans
is your AFC team would you say that or
no yeah yeah sure
and your NFC team is Redskins where did
that come from like my dad's from
Bethesda Maryland so they grew up going
to Redskins game so that's fine that's
fine you don't root for the Cowboys
against your dad but your mom you start
rooting for the Red Sox I mean what the
hell's going on in your family I know I
know I know
I know it's not good it is what it is
but hey so you Washington [ __ ] fan um
and you're a fan of LSU your fan of the
Texan
am I missing anything wrong okay my
team's just routine group for the
Rockets
okay and say again you're here in Los
Angeles check out your YouTube channel
at a brag underscore one on Twitter
what's your Instagram handle same thing
a brag underscore one yes sir okay
why was Alex Bregman taken I don't know
I just I grew up like an a-rod as well
as Jeter so I wanted to be like Evans
said a brag Oh a brag I got it
a brag underscore one I bet you a rod
can don't you think a rods know somebody
knows Olivia Copa don't probably come on
let's that maybe that's one of the
things you talk about is really majorly
for major league for or break bad news
breaking training to I cannot believe I
just went down that wormhole with the
allow the fragment it's great to see
here man so you're gonna be hanging out
in the in the house with a rod and
Yelich yes sir I knew at the Laker game
last night right yeah that was fun that
was uh it's pretty cool to see LeBron
that up close and personal he can he can
had you never seen LeBron play no I have
but I haven't sat courtside in
Washington play that was the first one
yeah courtside you didn't extend your
legs or anything like that right no no I
was could be careful I was very I was
very careful they're those these are
playing at such a high high speed a game
right ridiculous yeah and by the way can
we get that wall a little taller in
right field in your stadium I would love
that
can we just like build two more feet on
that thing I love that we can we can we
fix this rule about the fan region over
what's the rule that needs to be fixed
well I had a issue with it in Colorado
earlier in the year and then we saw
without to Vader in the postseason well
that's right you were pissed in Colorado
yeah you I mean but that was that was
the the dark side of Alex Bregman coming
out right okay well once it will not
come out you're really pissed yeah I
just I think it's tough I think it's
tough for you for for the rule to assume
you can't assume a double play right
tough for the rule to assume outfielders
gonna make a
a homerun robbing cat I agree with you I
agree with you at least a double I mean
you were so pissed it was almost as if
Trevor Bowers I want to reached over and
caught it we'll leave it right there
Alex Bregman it's great to see you here
on this show bud thank you really
appreciate you coming I hope this is the
first of many times like we'll chat
during the season if you're out here in
Los a little bit more I'd love to have
you on sir I'd really love the way you
play baseball man I really really do the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience